الآن رسالة من عائلتنا الموسعة CNN ،
نشعر بالحزن للإبلاغ عن
وفاة ابنة francesca kaczynski إلى cnn's andrew
kaczynski وزوجته راشيل لويز
بعد معركة استمرت لأشهر مع
سرطان الدماغ كانت تبلغ من العمر تسعة أشهر
فقط وأريد مشاركتها  معك ما
كتبه أندرو وزوجته لتتذكر
فرانشيسكا كاتشينسكي ، والمعروفة أيضًا باسم بيني أو بيني ،
ماتت في 24 ديسمبر
من مضاعفات السرطان في
حياتها القصيرة ،
كانت فرانشيسكا طفلة جريئة وفضولية ،
كانت لديها عيون بنية عميقة
عميقة تبعتها أيا كان والديها
كانت تفعل ذلك ،
كانت تحب تناول الطعام والالتفاف عن قرب
خاصة في الأمسيات
، استمتعت فرانشيسكا ، إحدى المعجبين بشارع السمسم في بروكلين ،
بالسير لمسافات طويلة في
جميع
أنحاء مدينة نيويورك
ولعب بوسطن بألعابها وبالوناتها أثناء حضور
علاج النطق والملاعبة ،
أي الاستيلاء على قطتها رايلاند واحدة منها
كانت الأنشطة المفضلة هي
التدرب على سريرها من جانب إلى آخر
، لقد أحببت رؤية والديها أندرو
كاتشينسكي و  راشيل راشيل واستقبلتهم
بأكبر ابتسامة في العالم وركلة متحمسة عندما
استيقظت من غفوة ،
كانت ابتساماتها العديدة تبعث على الإثارة
في جميع أنحاء العالم وكانت سخية معهم
حتى عندما كانت معظم الابتسامات
مغطاة
بأقنعة وحتى عندما  واجهت تحديات من شأنها
أن تخيف شخصًا بالغًا مثل تشخيص السرطان
أو الولادة بفقدان السمع في
الأشهر الستة الأولى من حياتها في نيويورك.
القوس الأحمر على رأسها
كمشجع افتراضي
للعبة بروكلين نتس ، تمكنت والدتها
من غمس قدميها في
المحيط الأطلسي هذا الصيف ،
وهي تجربة كانت فرانشيسكا
غير مبالية
بها خلال فترة وجودها في فاصولياء بوسطن ، وكانت قادرة
على تجربة الفرح حتى أثناء وجودها في
العلاج
قابلت هذا الإوز والبط السخيف
المتسكع في الحدائق بالقرب من المستشفى
، وزارت إفساح الطريق لتمثال فراخ البط
في حديقة بوسطن
العامة وقراءة الكتاب ما  في العديد من المرات في جولة واحدة
مؤخرًا على طول نهر تشارلز ،
اختبرت رحلتها الأولى على أرجوحة
شيء كانت أيضًا
غير مبالية تمامًا بكل
شخص في مستشفى بوسطن للأطفال
عالجت فرانشيسكا بحب ولطف ملحوظين كان
الأطباء والممرضات يلهثون بفرح
عندما رأوها  ابتسموا
عندما دخلوا الغرفة ، لقد عشقت
العلاج بالموسيقى
وكان لديها بعض من ضحكاتها الكبيرة الأولى وهي
تلعب مع بالون إلمو
شخصيتها المفضلة في شارع السمسم
التي حصلت عليها من متجر الهدايا بالمستشفى
أثناء العلاج المهني
في عيد الهالوين كانت ترتدي ملابسها مع
ممرضاتها في منزل محلي الصنع.  معكرونة فاجيولي ،
أظهرت فرانشيسكا لوالديها نوعًا
من الحب لم يعرفوه من
قبل ولن ينسوا أبدًا أن
قبعة صغيرة نجت من قبل والديها
وجدها
جدها وعمتها
وأبناء عمومتها
، وقد طلبت العائلة تقديم أي
تبرعات  تكريما
لفرانشيسكا إلى الحدث الخيري لدورة الشتاء PMC
والذي سيحدث الشهر المقبل مائة
بالمائة من كل حدث  إن الركوب أو جمع الدولار
يذهب مباشرة إلى معهد دانا فاربر للسرطان
طوال هذه المحنة برمتها
، كانت عائلة سي إن إن بأكملها تسحبها من أجل
فرانشيسكا وتبقي عائلتها قريبة
في أفكارنا
وصلواتنا وهذه أخبار مفجعة
لنا جميعًا
ولكننا الآن نطلب منك  للانضمام إلينا في إرسال
حبنا بينما نحاول رفعهم
في الأيام والأسابيع والأشهر الصعبة
المقبلة ،
يمكنك تكريم ذكرى الطفل فرانسيسكا من
خلال التبرع لمؤسستهم الخيرية
ولكن أيضًا من خلال إعادة الالتزام
باللطف
والرحمة البسيطة بينما تتذكر
الاحتفاظ بأحبائك  أولئك الذين يشعرون بضيق الليلة
يقدرون كل لحظة ولا يأخذون
شيئًا كأمر مسلم به
، أندرو وراشيل يظلون أقوياء نحن
نحبك ونعلم أن ذاكرة فرانشيسكا
ستكون دائمًا نعمة